as we continue with the author of the
bread I actually got my copy right here
oh I dropped it right here
vengeance former speaker that he's upset
because I said it's not going to do as
good as understanding Trump which was a
very important book this book says very
important things about national security
this is your passion you're not really a
commentator your I don't even think you
although you were one of the best
speakers you're one of the great
political visionaries you actually can
give a course to these idiots of
Washington today how to have urgency
keep your promises and getting things
done but this is your passion and it's
in models today's right from today's
headlines you said well yeah because
because I want I worry about our
national security I think this is the
most dangerous period since the 1962
Cuban Missile Crisis that's right I
think that we I think it's partly a
problem because we have verticals we
think okay we're going to deal with
North Korea but that's not it's not
North Korea its North Korea and the
terrorists and Iran and Russia and you
have to think networks of behavior and
the point we make in vengeance is what
if terrorists got to super tankers full
of fuel swapped it to the North Koreans
for nuclear material to make dirty bombs
and one of those ability and wanted to
deliver the old-fashioned way by a ship
because they weren't going to build a
missile that we could shoot down then
what happens and we have Brook grant
who's our marine major this is her third
volume and she works with a Mossad agent
who's a woman and with a Saudi Arabian
agent who's the man the three of them
are signed find these guys before this
stuff can get to the US or to Israel
orders the person gonna have the movie
rights got I got my personal movie
coming up here's so we got this battle
going on most I know most people feel
like me right now when you became
speaker you ended up balance in the
budget welfare reform but you also would
take out of your pocket a piece of paper
first hundred days we're going to do
these these ten items and you did them
you kept your word repeal and replace
seven and a half years you know how
aggravated I am that they weren't ready
for that moment yeah now it appears they
may not be ready for this moment in
terms of the tax bill which the
Forgotten men and women need
and bob Corker is in a war with Donald
Trump and I'm thinking this isn't gonna
help right the country and by the way
they hate him let's be honest here I
talked to people in that Senate room
when the doors closed and they tell me
exactly what said by Ben Sasse Lindsey
Graham Senator McCain Mitch McConnell
and and bob corker they don't like this
president look but by the summer of 1940
the only American president to be
elected four times was so disliked by
the Congress that he turned to General
George Marshall and said if we're going
to get an extension of the draft X is 41
we're gonna give an extension the draft
you have to go get it because none of
them trust me enough now this was the
president who arguably was the most
effective politician in American history
well at least he had three terms so for
the first year founding fathers designed
a system for independently elected
people in three different places and
it's really really hard as I want so I
want to say something though okay about
patterns here is a good example of what
you're talking about
I just pulled out the Paul Ryan postcard
that you could fill out if they passed
the tax bill 85 or 95 percent of all
Americans will be able to do all of
their taxes on a postcard saves about
five billion hours of paperwork and it
saves probably 100 bucks I'm not worried
about the house is sent over mr. speaker
280 bills there's a question only gotten
a hundred what third of the president's
appointments right it's a year what are
you doing what are they doing so part of
what I would suggest older brother talk
okay they're coming to the calm Hannity
down nothing not trying to calm you down
I'm trying to draw on as you know we
just did a online course called
defending democracy and which is people
we like I may do a course on how to
legislate because for them or for us for
the country including them especially
them yeah especially them because look
and then them includes the White House I
mean the first thing you do is you
understand this is a system designed to
be hard and
you screw it up it becomes impossible
why am I having a hard time and I think
I speak for a lot of people you asked
for the house in 2010 you get it right
yes for the Senate 2014 you get it yes
for the White House you get it right you
got it all and then you have all those
lead-up time let me just cut you
obviously you're right look the fact is
people have every right to be frustrated
with the Republican Party which
institutionally has been unable now for
10 months to get its act together
why how is that even possible well
because you had a brand new president
who'd never served in public office
you have a whole bunch of senators who
are very sceptic skeptical too hostile
you have a house that had I think 70% of
the members have been there for three
terms or less did you hear how pompous
and arrogant and what a jackass corker
sounded like in that New York Times
interview those are my words those are
your words I'm a creature of the house
and all I can say is that people when
they get unleashed I did this many times
in my career you could you were that for
some of I was there the night you were
elected Speaker that's saying and there
are moments that night when I said
things which if I had not I said how
much stuff about the fact that Hillary
and Bill were originally McGovern nights
yeah well guess what that that becomes
page one of the New York Times brand-new
speaker attacks president that was
stupid why would you why would you say
that mm-hmm and so I would say that my
advice to senator corker was a very
bright guy and the president Trump was a
very bright guy he'd be a promises
not just that call each other have lunch
and decide serving the country is more
important than fighting your brand new
book ventures kalisto's new book she
can't sell her the ladies all right
evidence for children's poking that's a
great series
yeah thank you for being with us and
we'll see you soon Hannity calm if you
want to get it